لياخذوا انتقامهم باخذ الجزر
اليمنية. هزلت ورب الكعبة.
واليوم تحكم الامارات سيطرتها
على باب المندب اليمني. الذي
العسكرية الخارجية. بينما تقوم
الدول المعتدية بمحاولة حل قضايا
والسوريين. احساس كبير بالجرح
الوطني المفتوح الذي يجعل سماء
تسطو الامارات على هذه الجزيرة
وعلى الجزر اليمنية بشكل عام.
خصوصا مع انقطاع النفط والغاز
الروسيين عن الغرب. هل تحاول
يتحكم باثني عشرة بالمائة من
العالمية. فماذا تركتم لملاك هذه
اسرائيلية فيها. وتحتل جزيرة
ميون التي تتوسط مضيق باب المندب
النور بعد سبع سنوات من الظلام
والدمار والخراب? توقفوا قليلا.
تضرب البلاد من اقصاها الى
اقصاها. وكل ما فعلته الامم
الامارات لم تكتف بنهب ارخبيل
سقطرى بل هي اليوم تبني قاعدة
الاستراتيجي. هل ترك الاماراتيون
جزرهم التي اخذتها ايران وجاءوا
في العراق وسوريا. هدنة لمدة
شهرين تلاها تمديد للهدنة لشهرين
الذي كانت انظار العالم تتجه الى
العملية العسكرية الروسية في
امريكا الاستفادة من ثروات وطن
جريح? لا حول لا قوة له؟ وهل
سيطول صمت الشعب اليمني على ذلك؟
هل ستستمر الامارات بتحيين ميناء
لانفسهم؟ تعاسة اليمن السعيد.
الوضع ليس افضل حالا مما هو عليه
القوات الامريكية من جهة اخرى.
والاراض سورية هي من تتلقى
عدن يجري خنق الشعب اليمني يا
اصدقاء باياد خارجية؟ تمتلك
الاراضي التي تحتلونها يا ابناء
زايد? لدى اليمنيين والعراقيين
هل كانت الهدنة في اليمن لنهب
ثرواتها? فاليمن يتمتع بثروات
اليمن ايضا واحدة من اجمل الجزر
في العالم. جزيرة سقطرى التي
طبيعية كالنفط والغاز. هل يتم
سرقة هذه الثروات مقابل الهدنة?
بجديد. فالشعب اليمني يعيش معظمه
تحت خط الفقر. والازمة الانسانية
بلدانهم واراضيهم مستباحة.
ومكانا سهلا لتنفيذ العمليات
ثم تمديد اخر لستة اشهر اخرى.
لكن على الارض فالهدنة لم تأتي
تحتوي على الالاف من النباتات
والحيوانات النادرة. لكن للاسف
فهل يجد الاجانب حلا للقضية
السورية لم يجده السوريون
الضربات في كل الاحوال. بينما
تتجه الانظار الى الاجتماع الذي
العراق ويثير فزع السكان. وفي
ابرز ذلك تأتي تركيا التي تبدي
وهنا يعلن العراق اختفاء تاما
لبحيرة حمرين في محافظة وجفاف
المتحدة هو الوساطة لاجل الهدنة.
لكن الهدنة كانت فقط لاجل ايقاف
سبعة مليون لاجئ سوري. وعلى
الارض في سوريا تتواجد القوات
بحيرة ساوة التاريخية في محافظة
المثنى. الى جانب انخفاض ملحوظ
تقوم تركيا باعتقال اللاجئين
السوريين وترحيلهم الى سوريا
عشرات السدود وتقطع مياه الانهار
العراقية. وكذلك تفعل ايران.
وماذا عن السلام الم يرى
اليمنيون بارقة امل بخروجهم الى
سيضم رؤساء كل من روسيا وتركيا
وايران لمناقشة الوضع السوري.
بتهمة ارتفاع الجرائم في البلاد.
ويوجد في تركيا نحو ثلاثة فاصل
الدول التي تعتدي عليها بحجة فرض
السلام. واي سلام الذي سيأتي به
تدك اهدافا كردية في سوريا.
وكانت الاهداف تتمثل بمعسكرات
فهلا تركتم العراق وشأنه. يا من
تعتبرون جيرانه. نزاع في الارض
والجرح دائما في الجسد العراقي.
مصائب العراق لا تأتي فرادى.
الاسرائيليين على مقتل قائد
الحرس الثوري قاسم سليماني.
الرافدين. وقتلت اكثر من مليون
عراقي واستولت على النفط ولا
في منسوب نهري دجلة والفرات.
الجفاف يضرب انهار وبحيرات
كارثة اخرى من الايرانيين. حيث
سقطت الصواريخ الايرانية على
اطلاق النار. وماذا عن ارتفاع
الاسعار ايتها الامم المتحدة?
من الاميريكان من قبل. حيث عاثت
الولايات المتحدة فسادا في ارض
مدينة اربيل. بحجة قصف قاعدة
اسرائيلية للانتقام من
زالت النفط الى اليوم. مهلا لم
تكتمل الكوارث بعد. هنا تأتي
ومخازن ذخيرة ومنازل تتوسط مرمى
النيران. اردوغان يقول ان في
الاخرين? الانتهاكات ضد العراق
لا تأتي من الاتراك وحسب فقد اتت
اوكرانيا. كانت الطائرات
والمروحيات والمسيرات التركية
السورية والايرانية والروسية مع
القوات التركية من جهة ومع
السيطرة على الموصل. وعلى
الاراضي العراقية والتي من ان
تبدأ في عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين
عندما تنتهي معاهدة لوزان التي
التركية طويلة الامد في العراق
وهي كذلك في سوريا. في الوقت
سوريا هي من اجل انشاء منطقة
امنة. عن اي امن تتحدث يا هذا?
تقيد الاتراك. وماذا بعد ايضا?
هل ستنتهي تركيا من قيودها لتقيد
عملية قفل المخلب العسكرية
التركية هي جزء من العمليات
عملية قفل المخلب. ليست الا
استعدادا لعملية شاملة لاستعادة
مسار زمني يحكم تطوراتها. سواء
على المدى القريب او البعيد. في
العراقية ضد المسلحين الاكراد.
وسرعان ما اطلقت القوات التركية
القوات الخاصة التركية ووحدات
الكومندوز. تقول التقارير ان
كوارث عراقية. مرت اكثر من اربعة
عقود من الصراع التركي مع حزب
ان بلاده هاجمت مواقع حزب العمال
الكردستاني في شمال العراق. وقد
العمال الكردستاني. وهنا اعلن
وزير الدفاع التركي خلوسي اكار
ابريل الماضي بدأت انقرة هجوما
بريا وجويا على جيوب محافظة دهوك
الضحايا عن الدوران. ضربات
وعمليات عسكرية تركية. ضربات
في سوريا حيث يتواجد الروس
والايرانيون والامريكيون.
المدفعية وطائرات الهليكوبتر
والمسيرات والمقاتلات. كما نشرت
شيئا منها? وذلك يعني ان العملية
والانتهاكات ستستمر بعيدا عن اي
ايها الاتراك? لم يحدد الاتراك
اهدافهم من العملية. وهل حققوا
سميت العملية بقفل المخلب. فهل
ستستمر العراق بتلقي هجماتكم
الناظرين. عن حال الدول العربية
نتحدث يا سادة. واليكم البقية.
السعيدة تعيسة. فقر وجوع وخوف
يعم البلاد. حال العرب لا يسر
وجميعهم يدعي التضامن مع فلم كل
هذا؟ الى اليمن حيث اصبحت
الجفاف. وفي الطرف الاخر. لا
تتوقف العمليات العسكرية لانقرة
ايرانية. وفوق هذا كله تعاني
بلاد نهري دجلة والفرات من
قالها الاتراك. لكن هل انتم
متأكدون يا هؤلاء? اذا لماذا لا
اراضي الجمهورية التركية كافية
بالنسبة لنا. لا توجد لدينا اي
يسمع انين اسود الرافدين في
العراق فقط? سقط اكثر من مليون
توقفوا هجماتكم في العراق
وسوريا? العراق الجريح يأن. فمن
شهيد سبب الغزو الامريكي. وفي
العراق اليوم لا يتوقف عداد
اطماع تجاه اي بلد سواء العراق
او سوريا او اي بلد اخر. هكذا
العدو. يا لحال العرب اليوم يا
سادة.